you've worked on Marvel and DC films
howdy the two universes differ in terms
of tone style and approach to
storytelling and what are some of the
challenges and opportunities that come
with working in each
um I don't think that there's any you
know I don't think you can
because relatively
um the MCU and now the DCU in film which
really doesn't start I mean the first
DCU character for sure is Blue Beetle in
the First full DC move DCU movie is
Superman
um
you know the now that that's happening
it's it's relatively new the same thing
with with Marvel I mean even MCU is
relatively new so I don't know if
there's any innate things about tone
because I think that what both MCU and
DCU need to do is to have a wider range
of tones than they presently do
um
I think they work to do that but I think
they can do a better job of it yep
um
the biggest but but if you look at the
MCU there are very few superheroes
the you know there are very few
traditional superheroes there was never
a guy with a secret identity until
Spider-Man in the MCU
their cap was turned into a soldier even
though he wears a mascot you know and
that's all there was in DC you know Iron
Man doubted himself at the end of the
first Iron Man because they don't want
to deal with the secret identity stuff
so there is a bit more of a fantasy
element to DCU
um because there are these Larger than
Life superheroes and you can't take that
you're not going to make I mean people
are going to do whatever they're going
to do in the future but for me you know
there's Superman and Clark Kent like
they're two different characters and you
have to find a whale to deal with them
um that's as grounded as possible within
this world of DC one of the things I
love about DC and excites me about DC is
that in a way it is it's another
alternate history you know it is Gotham
City and metropolis and Star City and
bloodhaven and and you know all these
different places in this this other
reality and it makes it a little bit
like Westeros in some ways
um I love that about it I love that we
get to create True World building in DC
it isn't just we're throwing some
superheroes on Earth yeah you know
I like that so I think that right now
that's one of the key differences what's
your favorite Marvel movie besides
Guardians
um MCU are Marvel both
my favorite MCU movie is Iron Man the
original yes love it I think it's
incredibly great movie
um but my favorite Marvel movie is
probably Deadpool which really well
actually no my favorite Marvel movies
into the spider-verse
people love that movie yeah everybody
loves them it's great I haven't seen it
yeah you haven't seen anything I know
I'm gonna see it oh dude it's the best
superhero movie ever made really I think
so you love it that much I do love it DC
favorite movie of all time DC movie uh
super first Superman I mean it's uh
behind you
signed by Gene Hackman oh that's pretty
cool you're better than you did a better